This is the last lesson in the grammar
of words where we're going to explore
some of the properties that don't become
apparent until we put multiple words
together, but that are still often
reflected in the form of words.
Remember that this entire time we've
been concerned with form morphology.
So let's consider for properties
possession, modification, agreement,
and government. Let's stick with those
four for now. Starting with possession,
it has a fairly descriptive name.
You can probably guess that it tends to
deal with one down possessing another
now, and that's the
gist of it. In English,
we show possession by adding an apostrophe
s suffix or clinic to the Noun that
is the possessor and placing that noun
before the noun that is the possessed.
Now an example would make this
clearer John's car or the dog's bone.
Both of these examples use the aloe morph
of the apostrophe s morphine to show
possession. Other languages show
possession in other ways. For instance,
the romance languages
used periphery assists.
So does modern German in languages that
have won a genitive case is perfectly
fine for showing possession.
So for instance,
in Latin [inaudible] [inaudible]
would be the girls dog.
And in that instance we do the reverse
of English in the romance languages.
A pair of frosted construction
developed that replaced the old Latin
construction. So you say the
equivalent of the dog of the girl,
and basically every romance language,
let's move on to agreement.
Agreement involves,
yeah,
there's one word matching the
same property of another word.
That's an awkward way to say it, but let
me give you some examples. In Spanish,
a masculine noun will be described by an
adjective that takes a masculine ending.
A feminine now will be described by an
adjective that takes a feminine ending.
We sum that up by saying that
the noun and the adjective agree.
The adjective agrees with the Noun.
That's a case of agreement.
The same thing happens in English
between subject nouns and verbs.
The word talks agrees with He.
So we would expect to say he talks,
but not I talks or you talks.
So talks agrees with the third person,
singular subject.
That's another case of agreement.
The verb has to take a third
person singular ethics to
show that it agrees with
the third person singular subject.
Let's distinguish
agreement from government.
The traditional account of government has
us look at the word that is governing.
In other words,
we look forward.
That forces another word to
comply with a certain property.
That's another awkward definition,
but let's move on to some examples.
In English we have prepositions if
they take a pronoun, in other words,
if they govern a pronoun like me,
we expect that the preposition is followed
by an object pronoun rather than a
subject. Pronouns. In other words,
the word accompanying the preposition
must be in the object case.
So I would say for me, but not
for he. I instead say for him,
I don't use the subject case Pronoun
after the preposition for or any
preposition for that manner.
I use the object case,
so we say that prepositions
English governed the
accusative case of pronouns or
the object case of pronouns.
It's very important to notice the
government applies to verbs as well.
If I say I saw him.
The verb.
See here in the past tense saw prompts
us to use an object case pronoun him
rather than another subject case Pronoun.
That's another example of government.
Contrast this with agreement.
Agreement matches a property equally well.
Government pushes a word to have a
property that the other word doesn't have.
Now let's talk about modification.
When an optional word is added,
that changes the meaning of another word.
It modifies that other word,
adjectives and adverbs are the
main modifiers. In English,
we have an example like the gray cat
ate dinner in which gray is an adjective
that modifies cat.
You can see that if we remove gray,
the cat's still makes sense.
Adverbs work similarly.
For instance,
if I say the rabbit runs swiftly,
swiftly modifies how the rabbit runs,
we could just say that the rapid runs,
the extra material isn't necessary,
but it does add something.
It modifies the action.
Notice that these properties start to
push us away from looking at the form of
words. We're already talking
about the arrangement,
the order of words and sentences,
and with that you're ready to move
on to the grammar of sentences.
I'm glad you stuck with me throughout
this series and thank you for learning.
I am.